you tweet all the time all the time you
know why i love you someone told me a
story about you in tweeting and i want
to know if it's true if it's not then i
don't like it i tell you the truth i
love this you were on a plane flight
and uh you were on in first class with
al pacino
and you sat there the entire plane
flight and tweeted what everything he
did yes oh really
no i love that oh that's hysterical
waiting to talk to him so if he goes to
the bathroom how's it going are you like
oh he's probably just peeing because he
came out fast
but he came out slow he took a big dump
like literally everything he did
what were some of the things you
observed that you tweeted and then he
was uh sat at the inside see yeah i ate
the entire dinner how far away from him
were you i was across the aisle also
near the window
uh three people separating us and i was
watching he had a good view of you and
you had a good view of him he didn't
notice you did he speak at the very end
he spoke i was so excited hey john i
liked your documentary i got so excited
and i said i loved your immersion in
venice but can't you change the ending
of jewish
yeah can't you be a different religion
it's not good
we laughed so you you i sense a crush on
him or something uh
just
i love these act you know i mean you see
well he's some actor you go oh my god
look at what this man has done you
didn't watch him in that cavorkian thing
dude i loved him in that i like
kevorkian i'm a big fan
i'm for killing everybody but i know
when it's time for you to go yeah don't
you wish you could be to be on the panel
you realize if joan was covering how
many people be gone around everybody new
apartments there would be i think
everybody in new york over 70. now that
should be just wiped out that's a great
reality show you and dr kavorki america
votes for which one yeah fantastic